a last second evasive maneuver by
JetBlue Pilots avoided a potentially
disastrous collision at Boston's Logan
Airport Monday night we got really close
and then instantly we are rocketing back
up into the area
despite that order to wait investigators
say a private leader jet entered the
runway to take off just as JetBlue
flight 206 was moments from landing on
the same Runway
the FAA says the private jets pilot
repeated back those instructions but
still proceeded to take off with the
planes coming only about 565 feet from
colliding FlightAware shows the JetBlue
plane roughly 100 feet from the ground
before it abruptly pulls out